what's your plan for getting to the
post-production process the editing the
importing footage deciding on how to
categorize things once you get into
Final Cut Pro close production I am of
the philosophy that if you can learn to
do as many things in this whole process
so I had never shot with a 5d before
season 2 so I learned about the camera
and then I had to learn about the post
because we shot the first season on a DX
2100 and 2000 so a standard definition
of old-school video where you're you
know plugging the camera in and zipping
and capturing little chunks of video
which took forever but with this process
where we're shooting three camera must
all the time so then that has to get
transcoded then all that sound has to be
synced using these PluralEyes I cut on
Final Cut uf7 Cut Pro 7 long final cut
and I do all the cutting I do all the
sound I do all the colouring nobody else
touches I leave with the cars and no one
sees anything until it's on youtube so
it's
what I think that you save in time like
I don't know an editor who would work
for the money that we had which was
nothing to cut 82 pages with this much
work some people like the idea of a
director in the editor being separate I
think that the that because I cut it and
I'm directing it and we don't have a DP
99% of the time that when we shot a
dinner scene for six and I can tell one
operator get this another operator can
you get that I'm gonna get this then I
in my head I'm sitting in front of Final
Cut Pro going okay so I have this I have
this I have this so I'm good
okay go as opposed to I don't know what
the editor is gonna want let's cover the
out of this thing is such a waste
of time so I I know what shot I need to
get this I know what I have to pick up
because I know how to cut so if I know
how to edit then it's one less job I
think it makes me a faster director it
makes me a better director it makes me a
better director of photography when I'm
playing that game and it makes it easier
for me to explain to the people I'm
working with who are shooting what what
I need and also I can just sit there on
my head and go okay so I thought okay
good go but with the fight scene that we
had I had a page and a half of inserts
because I needed to kill people and have
guns and cross bows and arrows and none
of we had no live fire nothing with
blanks we didn't do any of that so I I
looked through the script and I go okay
I'm gonna need that
write that down I need that I worth that
and then you end up with a shot list and
then it's going through and making sure
do I have everything I need and that
makes the post-production do I have room
tone you know I monitor what the boom
operator is doing so I have headphones
on while I'm operating a camera
and I can hear the mic is often neat if
I something picked up sometimes I'll
grab some wild sound of a door creaking
or something else that maybe I think I
can use because I also mix all the sound
and I to the color correction so all of
that makes a lot more work and I would
say if you're gonna cut your own stuff
it just it's gonna I don't know how much
time it's gonna take as I don't know how
fast you are but if you can learn how to
operate a camera and you can learn how
to edit and you can direct you can be so
much cheaper you can be so much faster
and even if you know a little bit about
it and you are working with another
editor you can at least say look you
know if we go from this shot to this
insert to this that's what I'm thinking
and if you never cut before where you
don't know kind of what that brain is
like you focus your brain on how that
works once you have all that stuff in
your head it the more you know
essentially the more you know about the
whole process the better you're gonna be
and I think it's worth it you know to
learn how to edit if you're a director I
think it's worth it to learn how to
operate a camera if you're an editor
because even if you are I've never been
a video village tent guy who's looking
at a monitor command like I want to
right there with the actor with the
camera I want to be right in the middle
of it I want to see like I know when the
shot go I get made fun of because I
always say cut
very nice there is a girl girls are very
nice cuz that's that's my gut reaction
like I saw it go through I'm like very
nice that's it we got it
next moving on or let's do another take
better about this I it's hard it takes a
lot of time and again it goes back to
make a story you love because when it's
1 o'clock in the morning and you're sick
to death of looking at these
shots and you can't figure out how am I
gonna get from this to this I love this
story I'll figure it out
as opposed to oh boy they're gonna buy
bull lows because of this that's a hard
to keep motivated about I think but yeah
learn the cop no matter what learn to go
you